on a parlé en début d'émission la
semaine dernière le lycée
franco-allemand de Buc célébré les 60
ans du traité de l'Elysée se traitait
Marc la réconciliation entre la France
et l'Allemagne après plusieurs décennies
de conflits
Morlaix vous êtes la proviseur du lycée
franco-allemand de Buc ce traité les
signer le 22 janvier
1963 et 60 ans après 1000 élèves ont
célébré ce pacte d'amitié entre
l'Allemagne et la France alors c'est un
moment attendu dans le lycée oui alors
nous avons travaillé depuis la rentrée
de septembre sur ce projet donc nous
avions le temps fort dont vous parlez
mardi dernier mais également toute une
semaine franco-allemande afin de
permettre à l'ensemble de notre
communauté scolaire de vivre cet
événement donc nous accueillons en effet
cette année plus de 1070 élèves qui ont
tous participé à cet événement de mardi
après-midi ce sont je le rappelle des
élèves du CP à la Terminale puisque le
lycée franco-allemand est une scolaire
entièrement public et nous avions donc
répartis la semaine avec un programme
assez vaste pour revenir sur cet
après-midi de mardi dernier le but était
non seulement qu'il y ait un temps
commun avec les millénaires réunis dans
la trium de l'établissement autour des
traditionnels discours mais aussi des
hymnes français européen allemand et
l'hymne du LFA puisque nous avons notre
propre notre propre musique et ensuite
de permettre à tous les élèves de
partager leurs compétences avec
différents ateliers je pense que vous
voudrez revenir sur
le but étant nous avions donc trois
rotations qui permettaient à tous les
élèves d'assister à un concert de
participer à un parcours artistique et
culturel et de visionner les vidéos de
notre concours inter et les femmes
puisque je rappelle que les autres
lycées franco-allemand
sont à Fribourg et à Sarrebruck en
Allemagne et les deux petits derniers
ont ouvert à Hambourg à la rentrée 2020
et à Strasbourg à la rentrée 2021 alors
quand est-ce qu'il a été créé ce lycée
c'est grâce à ce traité de très peu de
temps après le traité de l'Élysée a lieu
un accord intergouvernemental qui va
fonder la création des lycées
franco-allemand donc en ce qui concerne
but nous notre naissance remonte à 1975
et la structure à partir de là ne va
cesser d'évoluer puisque partie du
niveau lycée on redescend ensuite sur le
collège
quelques années après va on nous allons
voir l'ouverture d'une école allemande
qui est devenue franco-allemande il y a
deux ans et nous avons également notre
sein une section internationale
britannique de la seconde à la terminale
qui est importante souligner puisque
lors de ces temps forts nous nous avons
à cœur d'intégrer l'ensemble des élèves
de infrastructures afin qu'il puisse
être dans cette mouvance et dans cette
histoire franco-allemande mais surtout
mieux se connaître les uns les autres
l'amitié franco-allemande ça vous parle
autour du plateau Jean-Baptiste
harmonique
j'ai fait que classe européenne allemand
alors je n'engagement pas une
conversation parce que c'est pas comme
le vélo ça s'oublie mais puis je suis je
suis européen et vous savez à Villepreux
on a les commémorations du 8 mai mais on
a à cœur de célébrer aussi la Journée de
l'Europe et donc le 9 mai on propose
constamment quelque chose et l'auda la
joie en tout cas l'humeur européen est
un nime qui me qui me touche très
particulièrement donc félicitations et
bravo pour vos actions
et pas de classe européenne mais par
contre effectivement je trouve ça
intéressant de proposer ça aux élèves ça
se fait de plus en plus c'est une
ouverture de manière générale donc c'est
important
je suis originaire de Moselle donc
proche de l'Allemagne donc forcément
habitué dans mon enfance dans mon
scolaire avec des liens effectivement
assez étroits entre la France et
l'Allemagne on va revenir un petit peu
au programme de cette semaine pour
célébrer les 60 ans du traité vous avez
parlé de deux concerts est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus
oui alors nous avions différents pôles
avec notamment des conférences une
conférence d'un auteur allemand hands
sous le Richelle qui est au programme du
baccalauréat pour nos élèves puisque je
le rappelle nos élèves passe le
baccalauréat franco-allemand qui est un
diplôme spécifique donc nous avons eu la
chance d'accueillir monsieur traichel
jeudi dernier nous avions également une
une conférence plus historique vraiment
sur la création
oui la de ce traité de l'Elysée et sur
ses conséquences immédiates donc il y a
eu lieu vendredi après-midi grâce au
à l'Institut histoire allemande
nous avions à côté de ça des moments un
peu plus un peu plus partagés comme
l'intervention d'Arte avec Claire
Doutriaux qui nous a fait l'honneur de
venir animer et expliquer aux élèves
comment fonctionne les missions
carambolage donc c'était le mardi matin
et puis des temps purement festifs
puisque nous avons des élèves qui
regorgent d'imagination donc nous avons
eu la chance de tourner un livre dub
vendredi matin donc 3h de tournage avec
les 1000 élèves de la structure à
l'initiative donc de notre Conseil de
Vie Lycéenne donc tout a été pris en
charge par les élèves de terminale voilà
donc ça a été un grand moment et nous
attendons le résultat avec beaucoup
d'impatience et évidemment c'est ajouter
ce week-end puisque nos portes ouvertes
étaient
expressément placé ce samedi 21 janvier
afin d'accueillir les familles pour de
nos futurs élèves pour les examens
d'entrée et pour la rentrée prochaine
nous avions également un partenariat
avec la ville de Buc pour le concert de
Fire patch qui est un groupe de hip-hop
franco-allemand qui a eu lieu samedi
accessoires et puis dimanche grande
cérémonie officielle entre le président
Emmanuel Macron et le chancelier
olapsholtz à laquelle nous avons eu la
chance d'assister et bien merci beaucoup
Marie-Alix Marley d'être venue en parler
avec tout je le rappelle vous êtes
proviseur du lycée franco-allemand de
Buc